[Musik]
mit modifizierte stärke kann die
lebensmittelindustrie torten
tiefgefrieren zucker nachmachen kerle
über wasser gehen lassen und ganz viel
profit machen ein bisschen modifizierte
stärke und der geldregen kommt von ganz
allein sebastian deck den trick bei
fertig mariniertem grillfleisch auf und
macht mal so richtig kasse
sebastian lege will zeigen wie
verbraucher selbst beim grillen mit
stärke ausgetrickst werden
dazu hat er sich mit metzgermeister
bernd kruse in bochum verabredet
feuerbrand bekommen wenn unsere autos
jährlich
die beiden wollen fleisch marinieren das
sind ja außer dem kochstudio ja ja wir
haben ein bisschen was vorbereitet
woraus wir jetzt eine marinade die wir
vorstellen herstellen also reine weg aus
den rohstoffen das war eine maria 6 18
12 15 zutaten für eine marinade ja noch
was über ein aufwand da mach' mal deine
marinade ja und ich optimal die später
ein bisschen bernd kruse braucht viel öl
für seine marinade außerdem frische
kräuter paprikapulver pfeffer und salz
er mixt alles ordentlich durch und
fertig ist seine edle ehrliche marinade
wer anders sieht er richtig lecker aus
für die mal was ab und dann zeige ich
dir marinade richtig kasse machen jetzt
nur eine zutat macht den unterschied ich
hab hier modifizierte stärke und ganz
normale stärker als die mischung was
dafür sorgt dass die marinade auf die
oberfläche des gleich direkt gebunden
wird und natürlich dafür sorgt das ist
ein oder andere grenchen dazu kommt und
dann auch die kasse klingelt das ganze
geht so aus weizen kartoffeln oder mais
wird zunächst natürliche stärke gewonnen
zum modifizieren der stärke werden
chemikalien wie salzsäure
wasserstoffperoxid oder natronlauge
eingesetzt sie verändern die
molekülstruktur und die stärke bekommt
ganz unterschiedliche neue eigenschaften
produktentwickler sebastian lege setzt
auf modifizierte stärke die ohne
aufkochen öl binden kann so bleiben die
guten inhaltsstoffe in der marinade
erhalten gleichzeitig verwandelt sie
sich im handumdrehen in eine pudding
artige masse durch modifizierte stärke
entsteht eine lukrative zaubert zu tag
der lebensmittelindustrie ist braun
stück fleisch das sollte kein problem
sein wir sind ja in der fleischerei
[Musik]
wundervollen nacken von unserem
ruhrtaler freiland schweiz in bern
cruises metzgerei kommt fleisch aus
freilandhaltung auf den grill
jetzt würde ich das gerne siegen test
steht nummer 1 bringt 241 gramm auf die
waage das nächste stück fleisch wir
wechseln die schalen aber wir sind
wieder auf 0 249 und jetzt können wir
marinieren
metzgermeister kruse mariniert genau so
wie er es auch sonst für seine kunden
macht wie viel marinade genau verkauft
er mit seinen sticks
er rechnet nach zwölf grad gab es zwölf
gramm müssen echt spaß haben werden
[Gelächter]
sebastian lege dagegen geht beim
marinieren in die vollen
kummer bern schöner sarah kleben bleibt
240 gramm wanders was schätze wie viel
gramm habe ich gewonnen
naja so wie es aussieht 20 gramm
vielleicht sogar mehr weit daneben es
ist mir viel mehr wahnsinn 314 gramm
das ist tatsächlich unglaublich ja oder
ja ein bisschen modifizierte stärke und
der geldregen kommt von ganz alleine
der mäster verkauft sein grillfleisch
mit gerade einmal vier prozent marinade
durch modifizierte stärke besteht
sebastian legistik zu 23 prozent aus
marinade kundenzahlen da drauf ich finde
so allerdings trotzdem besser weil es
ist natürlicher und ordentlicher und ich
werde dabei bleiben
eine stichprobe im supermarkt zeigt der
marinaden anteil ist tatsächlich hoch
das grillfleisch enthält zwischen 10 und
20 prozent marinade
bei dem spirit von tillmanns ist selbst
das noch nicht die ganze wahrheit 20%
marinade sind auf der verpackung
deklariert doch im 80-prozentigen
fleischanteil stecken noch einmal 10
prozent flüssig würze das bedeutet
unterm strich liegt der anteil billiger
wird saucen nicht bei 20 sondern bei 28
prozent
[Musik]
möglich macht das modifizierte stärke
die in diesem fall gleich doppelt
eingesetzt wird
an sich ist modifizierte stärke
kein problem für den verbraucher ist es
keine gesundheitsgefahr
aber natürlich ist es ärgerlich wenn
durch den einsatz von dieser
modifizierten stärke vielmehr volumen
vorgetäuscht wird oder das produkt
einfach schöner aussieht als es
eigentlich ist
auch aus tiefkühl torten ist
modifizierte stärke nicht mehr
wegzudenken
in frucht füllungen und in tiefgekühlter
ware ist sie enthalten selbst saftig
weiße berliner aus dem supermarkt setzen
auf die besonderen eigenschaften der
modifizierten stärke
warum das so ist weiß kaum einer besser
als matthias mittermaier
jahrelang hat er herum experimentiert
jetzt kann er aus wasser und stärke
sogar luftballons herstellen
er weiß weiße zucker haben gibt es im
supermarkt nur wenn mit stärke getrickst
wird
das ist niemals bruder zu geben er hätte
sich schon längst auch bitte der glas
folie schon längst aufgelöst hobbybäcker
haben es vielleicht schon einmal welt
erlebt puderzucker als kuchen dekoration
ist höchst vergänglich weil er sich mit
feuchtigkeit vollsaugt und auflöst
matthias mittermeier kennt die lösung
des problems speziell modifizierte
stärke sorgt dafür dass der zucker auch
nach stunden noch schneeweiß und trocken
aussieht
im handel wird die mischung als dekor
schnee verkauft
was ist süßer schnee oder auch dekor
schnell das ist stärke dextrose
ebenfalls aus der stärke gewonnen wird
mit palmfett ummantelt somit den
kühlschrank absolut stabil und dazu
gelöst sich nicht auf bei taten aus dem
tiefkühlregal sorgt die modifizierte
stärke dafür dass sie auch nach jahren
appetitlich aussehen sahne füllungen
bleiben durch den zusatz auch nach dem
auftauen so flüssig wie am ersten tag
am beispiel einer frucht füllung
demonstriert matthias mittermaier die
vorteile von modifizierte stärke
im ersten schritt stellt er eine frucht
füllung mit klassischer stärke her damit
sie die frucht masse bindet muss
matthias mittermaier die mischung auf
kochen was den industriellem maßstab
eine menge energie verbraucht
[Musik]
mit modifizierte stärke dagegen ist
kochen überflüssig sie bindet die frucht
masse auch in kaltem zustand
das spart jede menge zeit und energie
und bringt noch weitere vorteile mit
sich
[Musik]
hat man kochte variante einmal kalt
angerührte modifizierte stärke chemisch
verändert worden ist allerdings habe ich
vor farbe purer der schmack alle
vitamine erhalten
natürliche herstellung war zeitaufwands
energiekosten durch das kochen farbe
geschmack und vitamine gehen kaputt
links im bild die gekochte stärke rechts
die kalt angerührte farblich ein
deutlicher unterschied tiefkühl torten
werden also erst durch modifizierte
stärke strahlend schön
soweit bekannt kommt keiner der großen
hersteller ohne die chemisch veränderte
trick zutat aus sebastian lege will noch
einen draufsetzen und beweisen dass
modifizierte stärke sogar richtige
zaubertricks möglich macht er will über
wasser gehen spannung steigt sinken oder
laufe ich über das wasser
1250 liter wasser und 700 kilo stärke
kann dieses gemisch wirklich einen 100
kilo mann tragen
es kann ich kann übers wasser laufe
stärke verwandelt wasser in eine
substanz die weder fest noch flüssig ist
plötzlicher druck macht die masse so
stabil dass sie über 100 kilogramm
tragen kann
super zutat stärke bei grillfleisch
nutzen sie manche hersteller um
möglichst viel marinade ans fleisch zu
binden
gut für den profit schlecht für
verbraucher die ihr geld für marinade
stadt für fleisch ausgeben
bei torten dagegen geht es nicht ohne
modifizierte stärke nur so behalten sie
auch nach jahren in der tiefkühltruhe
noch ihre strahlend schönen farben
[Musik]
was haltet ihr von der besonderen stärke
sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonnier die zdf
besser esser und schauten die nächsten
zwei clips